[Music]
as the MCU reaches its darkest hour
killing half of your favorite heroes in
an instant
Marvel's next movie will answer the
least important question on everyone's
minds where was Paul Rudd and man in the
Oise return to the franchise that
everyone likes but no one really cares
about in this satisfying episode of
Marvel season 3 episode 8 and while you
don't need to see the first ant-man to
know what's going on you definitely need
to catch up on Captain America Civil War
especially if you're in the movie I
really screwed up because they didn't
tell me when we started this but I
should go see Captain America so when I
read the script for this I had no idea
that begin what was going on you are
everyone's dead right now mr. Douglas
and I love you for it
the cutest Marvel white boy not named
Chris returns as ant-man the hero who
toes the line between effortless charm
and just plain effortless
he'll team up once again with Hank Pym
the guy who invented an end to world
hunger then used it to build fighting
suits Paul Van Dyne the first female
Marvel hero in a movie title and like
the fifth female Marvel hero playing the
series when rolling her eyes at a goofy
male counterpart and Louise who makes up
for being the MCU movies only Mexican
character by being the absolute most
Mexican character oh my would lead to
how to do pots in a restaurant yeah
only play more see you embark on a
feature-length game of capture the lab
of a range of spires for your lab you
got the lion got to get that land back
we need to regroup and figure out with
well happy Sims lab is done get my lab I
won't that loud
I'll get the lab Wow Bert's got the lab
lab I got the lab
as our heroes race to save michelle
pfeiffer from 30 years in the quantum
realm a CGI Wonderland made of Doctor
Strange outtakes Easter eggs and I guess
beauty supplies because she came out of
there looking nice but hot on their
tails is ghost a girl who just wants to
cure her chronic pain and gets the snut
beaten out of her for trying
that'll teach you not to want pain and
last but definitely least sunny birch a
regular guy with a couple of goons a tan
suit in a crappy restaurant I guess I've
also committed numerous health code
violations in my restaurant come on
where's this tech super moss
he's going after Ford the strongest -
people in the MCU with nothing but a
cellphone on a dream oh come on iron
fist could beat this guy iron fist
enjoy all the visual and memory you've
come to expect we're little things are
in bigand
and big things are constantly belittled
if you two are finished comparing sizes
creating awesome action scenes that spit
in the face of physics but according to
marvel you can make science do anything
if you just let the word quantum on it
quantum realm quantum technology quantum
anomaly quantum phase Ponte spectrometer
and quantum system quantum energy
quantum reason plot oh boy quantum
entanglement between the quantum states
quantum healing particles did you guys
just put the word quantum in front of
everything hey stop calling at your own
lazy explanations
that's our job so enjoy a film that
managed to be funny and compelling with
good action and great effects that would
have blown everyone's mind less than 10
years ago this is awesome but because it
doesn't further marbles 19 movie super
plot enough nerds will treat it like a
pesky insect how many planets do they
visit just one the pass I don't get out
of bed for anything less than the
celestial a good day sir
starring big hero sticks Smalling down
if you like it then you should have put
a thing on it
dumb Zemo definitely not Nick Fury
office park a bug's wife phasing Anthony
Mackie and Kevin and the fudgie's West
Coast Avengers
I hope all the furniture is both the dad
before you did that awesome I hope you
have a septic tank because those toilets
are not hooked up to anything I got some
ants in my pants hobo party at Connie's
reversed the polarity of the neutron
flow Eddy cooperate like a turd in the
wind balls
James balls James damaged balls